[موسيقى]
هذا مثل مكاني السعيد ، كما تعلمون ،
بغض النظر عن الحالة المزاجية التي أنا فيها
بمجرد أن أقود خلف عجلة القيادة في سيارة
خارقة ، أشعر
بالسعادة عندما يبدأ الأدرينالين
في الارتفاع وقد استمتعت به حقًا
ما الأمر  ما الأمر ما الأمر
يا رفاق ، إنها سيارة بلوندي خارقة أنا أليكس
هيرشي ،
معروف باسم السيارة الشقراء الخارقة ،
أنا أطارد أروع
السيارات وأقوم بتصويرها لجمهوري وأضعها
على
جميع أنواع منصات التواصل الاجتماعي المختلفة ،
وهكذا على فيسبوك بعض مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بي  لديك
نصف مليار مشاهدة
كما تعلم ، وهذا جنون ،
لطالما أحببت السيارات
بمجرد أن تدخلها
، فحينما أتيت إلى دبي
انفجر اهتمامي لأن دبي
هي المكان الذي يمكنك من خلاله
مشاهدة السيارات الفاخرة  كل
يوم وهناك عدد قليل جدًا من الأماكن في
العالم حيث يمكنك تجربة
القيادة حرفياً في جميع أنحاء
دبي وسترى سيارات خارقة
أه يمكنك إيقاف هذا الفندق من فئة الخمس نجوم ،
وستكون دائمًا سيارات خارقة
متوقفة في الخارج
هم فقط  إنها ثقافة قيادة ضخمة في كل مكان في المدينة
وما أحبه في دبي هو كيف
يسهلون ثقافة القيادة ،
فأنا جزء من اثنين من نوادي السيارات الخارقة
هنا في
المدينة وبدلاً من محاولة الحد
من متعة الناس ، يحاولون فعلاً
تسهيل ذلك.  هذه المتعة ولكن بطريقة آمنة ،
سيكون لدينا مرافقة شرطة في المقدمة أو
مرافقة شرطة في الخلف فقط حتى تتم
هذه الرحلات
بأمان
إذا لم يكن للعيش هنا ، لا
أعتقد أنني  سأفعل ما أفعله الآن
أنا لست خبيرًا في السيارات ولن
أدعي أبدًا أنني
خبير سيارات ، أحد الأسباب التي جعلت
منصتي تعمل
ونوعًا من الانفجار في تلك السنة الأولى
هو أنني تحدثت عن  السيارات من
منظور الشخص العادي
عندما تحرك عجلة القيادة ، انظر إلى
ما يحدث للشاشة ،
لم أعتقد أبدًا أن هذه ستكون وظيفة
حصلنا عليها هنا في دبي ،
وهو أمر
رائع تعرفه مثل أكثر من 50 مليون
متابع في ثلاث سنوات وأنا '  لقد
فعلت كل
ما تعرفه با  سيدي هنا ، من الواضح أن الجزء المفضل لدي
من العمل
هو في الواقع أن
أقود السيارات
كان هدفي هو امتلاك سيارة خارقة ذات
يوم والآن يمكنني في الواقع أن أقودها لكسب
عيش مجنون